tja jetzt fragen wir uns mal wie weit
eigentlich diese klimakaoten noch gehen
wollen die kleben sich ja nun auf den
Straßenfest das kennen wir schon die
beschädigen auch Kunstwerke jetzt Kapern
sie aber auch unsere Ministerien unser
Parlament und sie werden dabei immer
radikaler
[Musik]
das dritte Mal in nur einer Woche drei
Aktionen der klimakaoten in nur drei
Tagen der aktuelle Vorfall rote Beete
Saft vor dem Verkehrsministerium
Montag stürmen Demonstranten das
Bundesministerium für Finanzen
[Musik]
das momentan in diesem Moment besetzen
etwa 30 Aktivisten das Finanzministerium
sie wollen auf die missliche
Schuldensituation des globalen Südens
aufmerksam machen Deutschland spielt
dabei eine wichtige Rolle
die Besetzer schaffen es bis ins
Vorzimmer von Minister Christian Lindner
geben sich als Besuchergruppe aus
bereits am Sonntag Kapern klimakaoten
das Gebäude in dem der deutsche
weltklimagipfeltagt kleben sich am
Eingang fest Gerechtigkeit weltweit kann
die an die Demonstranten und fordern
jetzt
im Inneren des Gebäudes spricht der
Kanzler als plötzlich Feueralarm
ausgelöst wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der Protest wird schließlich von der
Polizei aufgelöst ob der Alarm
tatsächlich durch die Besetzer kam
bleibt ungeklärt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
von klimakaoten vor einer Woche
nachweislich ausgelöst wurde der
Feueralarm im Bundestag wir befinden uns
im klimanopffall und die Regierung ist
dementsprechend reagieren deshalb werde
ich hier gleich im Bundestag den
Feueralarm aus
über 40 Feuerwehrleute Rücken an um auf
den falschen Alarm zu reagieren brauchen
jetzt eure Ticket ich frage mich
mittlerweile sogar ob die Regierung die
Situation noch im Griff
Besetzungen Straßenblockaden Fehlalarme
die Aktionen und Aktivitäten der
klimakaoten häufen sich ziviler
Ungehorsam oder Vandalismus fakt ist
immer mehr Menschen überschreiten die
Grenzen des friedlichen Protestes weil
ihrer Meinung nach nicht genug gegen den
Klimawandel unternommen wird
zeigt auch eine Missachtung
demokratischer Institutionen und einen
Willen Recht und Gesetz zu brechen der
in einem Demokratie fehl am Platz ist
die Straftaten die da begangen werden
können wir aus den Videos natürlich nur
teilweise sehen das sind sicher
Sachbeschädigung Hausfriedensbruch und
vielleicht kommt noch das eine oder
andere dazu
Politiker verlangen dann immer es soll
mit der ganzen Härte des Gesetzes
geahndet werden etwas das ist gar nicht
gibt denn es gibt immer nur eine Tat
angemessene Strafe und solange die diese
Sachen nicht geahndet werden wird dass
ich ja weitergehen
[Musik]
wir können uns nicht noch mehr Öl und
Gasverbrauch leisten
sorgt euch mehr um ein Gemälde als um
das Wohl unseres Planeten und der
gesamten Menschheit
[Musik]
wohnen in nur drei Tagen dreimal
schlagen die klimakaoten vor politischen
Institutionen zu was erwartet uns an Tag
4 steht die Eskalation der klimaproteste
bevor
[Musik]